i feel the only thing about nintendo
world that i was like
oh that's a bit weird was a toad
speaking japanese
oh really what does that sound like
because when you go into toad's
cafeteria there's like on like a
projection screen there's like toad like
in the kitchen like preparing food and
stuff and he like
notices you coming in and he's like well
yeah he only tries hey like kind of
thing but in japanese and i'm just like
oh no that's that's weird don't talk
yeah and
in japanese games he they use the
english the well what it's bad english
but they're recording
yeah but they use like that like type of
voice but then at the theme park they
can't
get away with just he's just like yeah
and i'm just like oh that's that's weird
just just go
and then just be with us
yeah that was that was the only part
where i was like because like same thing
happened in harry potter world because
we went to like one of one of the rides
of harry potter world is that
you go into the hogwarts and it's like a
kind of 4d
interactive like it feels like you're on
a broom and going through yeah
harry potter and stuff like that and
it's really [ __ ] cool and intense
yeah
the only thing that threw me off is
daniel radcliffe speaking japanese
i'm speaking radically honestly everyone
was speaking japanese
they have like a british japanese accent
no it was just literally just like they
just grabbed a random like
anime voice actor and i was like yeah i
was just like
i was like oh this is weird daniel what
happened to you bro
it's like an anime double line that he
whipped out the best line it was just
like when you uh
there's a there's a scene where you like
go like fight through all the dementors
and he's like i think in the english
version you can actually see daniel
radcliffe mouthing me like
wow that was a close one wasn't it or
something like that but in the japanese
one he was like
i'm just like oh damn you're white why
were they masking my boy like that
they used to say the english spells what
do you mean oh yeah yeah
the it's the english spells but said in
japanese oh what is it
so it's like in katakana yeah yeah so
it's like it's not like wingardium
leviosa it's like
wingard
i don't know why it's so funny yeah
foreign people trying to speak english
very funny yeah yeah but
overall nintendo out of ten like
solid nine i reckon no no ten really
makes you feel like mario
wait how much was that t-shirt i must
know what was this one yeah
this one was the uh three thousand five
hundred yen
it's not too bad i was expecting you'd
be like fifty dollars
i mean there were like fifty dollar ones
as well yeah really what were they like
designer gucci okay one of them i
actually bought it because it looked
really cool because it was at the uh it
was next to bowser's castle
and there was like uh they themed the
merch store next to the vr
mario kart yeah as like it looking like
the inside of like a mario kart garage
so they had like all of that there was
one shirt that i bought that had like
you know like in a lot of like uh car
racing like jackets
that have like all the patches of like
all the sponsors oh that sounds cool but
it was a shirt and all the patches were
like
mario themed so like that was really
cool and i was like
oh 55 bucks [ __ ] it i'll take it i would
yeah sometimes for me it's like it's not
about the prizes like does it look
cool and is it a thing that i can only
get here man i'll probably [ __ ] get
it
that's that's why they can hike up the
price right exactly
take my money nintendo you've been
taking my money for 26 years now
i'm not going to be what